s'ils font plus de 50% rien ce matin
[Musique]
regarder les écrans là et en fait c'est
directement relié voilà non je veux
blesser la love machine c'est vraiment
vrai il ya deux capteurs qui sont reliés
à bluetooth et qui sont reliés voilà en
bluetooth à un écran vous le dis on va
mettre les mains et on va voir notre
compatibilité ça marche d'accord
attention et divine et elle s'est parée
parce que c'est bon leur origine mais
attend elle est posée mettez bien
vaudois isabelle isabelle avec moi je
repars avec l'or nous et on a ces morts
de chez mozilla mes vieux beau nom mais
va rien faire du tout dans les vieux
pots la sas et partez pas les examens
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je veux voir déjà à -80% baba calme toi
c'est que du vrai attendant c'est parti
3 90e voilà 0
[Applaudissements]
ça rigolait pour l'instant c'est
benjamin castaldi
je voulus jeu fera ce matin valérie à
celui qu'elle est non non non voilà ça
c'est benjamin est dur c'est que ça
m'arrange pas dieu sait que ça m'arrange
pas c'est parti de la rose s'est bloqué
et on va le faire demain au stade
rennais y mettez votre main j'avais
mangé des boulettes à la tête de mangane
et dalmat vers la beauté de la vie ça
mon verre elle à larissa sur les masses
un mot je ne marche pas si vous avez
mangé des prix cassés ou moi on y va
elle a mangé des chaussures aux tons sur
ma vie
[Applaudissements]
ap ap
attendez attendez ça les partis ni jean
michel larqué dans la course au corps
c'est pas fini il est à terminer par
kelly on sait jamais eu un jean-michel
d'abord je passais le pire je veux pas
c'est bien pour l'instant benhaim suis
très content 1
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
elles sont pas des augmentations
ça me rassure et franchement jean-luc on
a mis plus d'un an
ça devrait manier match ça devrait poser
autour de moi ça veut rien dire ça
sous-entend que moi je vous aime pas
partie pour l'instant c'est bella imac
[Applaudissements]
77% jamais tu sais ce que tu peux
compter et ses propos on va pas leur
dire cessé mes deux plus proches ces
sachets le bois jamais eu déjà dit je
vous aime beaucoup les autres bah oui
oui vous allez faire avec max plaignent
alors avec max cilla plus de 50% entre
vous deux après le mach 3 2
jones m photo cl ou alors ça allait il
est dit que j'ai beaucoup de points
communs avec fatou à ça m'arrange pas
partie 3 2 1
[Musique]
on n'a rien dit et maxime associez-vous
beinheim ce but n'est pas de se moquer
on est franchement ça paraît avec
attention c'est parti ce sens le
dosseret nom et des moissons pas du tout
absolument pas
alors qu'en mai n'ont lâché
[Applaudissements]
oh
à la longue
c'est maxime gainey si l'on va faire
d'abord maxime
[Applaudissements]
la formation c'est vraiment calculé au
nom sans rigoler ces matières
scientifiques
voilà c'est sûr que c'est vrai ici les
siens alors bas mais en tout cas merci
de ta sagesse et réalise que c'est que
la complicité la compatibilité c'est
qu'on m'a dit moi bon alors il ya des
projets communs s'il ya un projet commun
partir en tunisie
y'a de la connexion intellectuelle 1 on
est on adore castanier la connexion
émotionnelle c'est dire que vous
ressentez vous reçoit dès la connexion
de sexuel c'est là on aura zéro lettres
et de la connexion spirituelle c'est à
dire vous avez quand même des valeurs
qui vous rassemble à l'héroïne on en a
beaucoup c'est sûr ça va faire 100%
allez vas y et j'adore ce qui fait qu'on
veut mais si on y va prévenir après moi
très vénérés après moi vous êtes
formidable mais je vous aime beaucoup
mais restait tout l'émission et doux à
oui c'est un truc ou alors on emballe
après on parle d'un truc
une émission qui marche pas on parle
d'amour bonsoir
j'aimerais de minutes jouées en forêt
dominés devant forêt car edward e minute
merci attention c'est parti
concentre toi bah c'est pas la peine de
faire c'est plus tard la chance de
marquer la main les plus grosses tables
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
maxime est calme or là là là ça leur
temps au lot ni s'il faut plus de 50%
rien ce match oui bien sûr à 2 ce matin
dans l'émission l épreuve n est pas là
pour ça et ça devient des corps n'est
pas dégueulasse ça l'est toujours
c'est plus drôle de voir un sommet
contre vous étiez lien pagis astériens
cache ta joie toile y est c'est bon et
on en est au niveau du boulevard des 10
millions de personnes
[Musique]
voilà
m